[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bringing
kristoff's manics uh sports illustrated
nba senior writer let me start with the
uh the tragic story of
what happened with kyrie stepping on the
celtics logo
as a former ball boy at the garden
how do you feel are you okay to talk
today about what happened
it took me 24 hours to
really get comfortable expressing my
feelings but yes
i'm i'm ready to talk to him
uh is there etiquette with this like
did he do something that's egregious
here is
he's never going to be forgiven i mean
celtic fans
don't like him anyway but well yeah look
stepping on the logo and the way kyrie
did you can certainly say it's
disrespectful i mean kevin garnett
obviously took umbrage
uh with it and we've seen stuff like
this in the past
with terrell owens on the star in dallas
and
and things like that it's it's but it
certainly doesn't warrant
it's you can't compare getting a bottle
thrown at you whether it's a
water bottle whatever tossed at you as
as some kind of equivalent there but
it's
the i mean kyrie
the anger boston fans feel towards kyrie
is not different
than the anger oklahoma city fans felt
towards kevin
kevin durant or cleveland fans back in
2010 fell
towards lebron james like he left they
were you know
going to he said he was going to stay
they believed he was going to be part of
something big there he left
so they're mad like that's it's really
not all that complicated when it comes
to kyrie irving
i haven't heard much from the
commissioner about these fan
incidents here but you know you're
you're really
wide open here you're you know when we
think of nba players you can sit right
next to a player on the bench you can
reach out and touch that player
there's no other sport that's like this
so what options does the nba have
in trying to curb this well you've seen
already
in the last couple of days more enhanced
security
in these arenas and maybe as
things go forward if this doesn't stop
you'll see
even more security whether it's
presences from security guards that are
more visible
on the floor or some kind of taping of
some kind
or a blockade of some kind for the fans
sitting courtside but i think from what
i
when i talk to people within the nba
about this it's still they're still
trying to formulate strategies beyond
just the enhanced security
that they've already implemented i think
what the nba is hoping
and this isn't really within their
purview but you know that
the punishments that are doled out uh by
authorities
dissuade this type of behavior now i do
think charging the fan in boston with
assault and battery a felony is a little
bit much but
i think some kind of legal repercussions
where
people that do stuff like this have to
either
pay a substantial fine uh community
service
something that comes with uh some teeth
to it because you know dan
banning a guy from marine it doesn't
really work i mean
it's not like you're gonna have this
guy's picture like on a proverbial milk
carton
in the arena like you can still come in
and out i think there's got
there's the hope that punishments with
more teeth
will dissuade this type of behavior do
you know what the alcohol
policy is at nba games like a lot of
baseball games will say
seventh inning they stop yeah i mean
alcohol is playing a role
in this yeah i i believe i don't know if
it's
universal but most venues the most areas
i've gone to is that
end of the third quarter you can't serve
beer after that so it's almost like
baseball where they recognize the
the end is coming and over the last 30
minutes of the game you're not allowed
to
to go buy it which of course sends
people running to you know the
vendors to you know buy six at a time
and go back to their seats that way so
it's not it's not a perfect solution but
that's
what most arenas i've been around go
with i applaud doc rivers for
standing up to uh those who doubt ben
simmons
but like ben simmons
has not gotten better he's he's there's
a ceiling with ben simmons
and while i i understand what doc is
doing
ben simmons is not a great player and
maybe it's not his fault it's our fault
because we thought he was going to be
the next magic johnson
where do you stand on ben simmons and is
he a good player
is he a very good player is he a great
player i go very good
um great is usually reserved for
the mvp candidates at least every single
year and i agree with you i think ben
simmons has
a ceiling especially offensively um
you know i think what he does great is
better than
the top 1 of the nba defensively
he's in the top 1 running a fast break
he's in the top 1 but over the years and
we're now at that kind of
mid-20s point of ben simmons career
where you'd expect to see some growth in
certain
areas you're not really seeing it you're
not seeing it at the free-throw line
you're not seeing it from three-point
range he's still not comfortable pulling
up from
really anywhere outside the paint uh so
i'm not expecting at this stage of ben
simmons career for that to substantially
improve
as it goes forward i still think he can
be a key cog on a championship team
because that defense and that uniqueness
to his to him playing the point guard
position
is incredibly valuable but i i think
we're past the point dan
where we're waiting for ben simmons to
reach that next level
i don't think that next level is going
to come he can still be great or still
be really good
but i don't think that next level for
ben simmons is going to be there
brooke lopez didn't hit a three for
seven years in the nba
then he became a good three-point
shooter like this can happen
and it's not that ben's form is bad on
his jumper
he doesn't bend at the free throw line
like it's very stiff
it just feels like you know it's
confidence uh you know lonzo ball the
same way like you get to the point where
now you're comfortable with this but um
you know i even said to reggie miller
ben should reach out to you you could
help him from the line you could help
him from three-point range
but i don't know what kind of i don't
know what ben wants to be
or you know and so that's what when doc
says this i'm like okay doc
you know he's like he's great we don't
see greatness with ben simmons because
what's he do
he guards somebody uh he'll have a pass
on a fast break and he'll rebound
okay there's nothing great there where
you go oh my god did you see ben simmons
when's the last time you said do you see
ben simmons last night
it doesn't happen well i mean i i've
done i have done that i mean when when
ben
has these great games where he puts up
like 20 15 and 15 like those are great
performances they're not empty stats
he's doing it but
there still comes the time in the fourth
quarter where you're worried about him
getting hacked instead of the free-throw
line you're worried about teams
scheming to leave him alone on the
perimeter knowing he's a non-threat it's
tough to play
four on five offensively at the
championship level so that's what's
going to stop ben simmons
from from getting to that next level
he's chris mannix
sports illustrated nba senior writer how
concerned
should the lakers be i think you're very
concerned
um i mean obviously the davis injury is
is pretty scary considering you know
he's he's going to be out most likely
for game five
and with these the series moving quickly
you don't know if game six is going to
be available either
and they were a very average team
without davis during the regular season
19 and 17
uh was the record um i you know and
on top of that in this series you know
he's been
largely their front court production i
mean andre drummond who was brought in
like for this reason to match up with a
deandre ayton
has been getting completely outplayed by
aiden it wouldn't surprise me to see
marc gasol
in the starting lineup in this game five
i think gasol
has proven to be a better fit with this
team offensively at least
in this particular series so if you're
the lakers it can't just be
a superhuman lebron performance like
it's got to be marc gasol
shooting a high percentage it's got to
be kyle kuzma having a breakout
offensive game
what i saw from chris paul suggests to
me that that shoulder is getting better
and if he can get to be
75 80 percent of what he usually is
there's enough weapons on that phoenix
team
at home uh to beat the lakers in game
five and to win this series
are you picking the suns
yes
this is gonna bite me again because
every time every time
i go against lebron i lose so take that
for what it's worth
yeah he put me on i didn't even think
about who i was picking until that exact
moment but this is
eventually going to make me look stupid
so yes
yeah you're aware that lebron's on the
lakers right
i am okay i just want to make sure
because this hasn't gone well like in
the last 12 years it feels like you go
against lebron you're like paul pierce
you don't like lebron
i do like lebron i i just for some
reason
i i sort of like convinced myself that
other teams can beat it like i was doing
that with
i think i did that with atlanta at one
point you know during lebron's tenure
which was incredibly stupid
in hindsight um but like you know boston
several times over um on your show i
think i said it was more likely than not
that the lakers don't make the playoffs
which
a clip that i was made to eat over and
over again on social media for almost
two years
so uh but why don't you go
with lebron well i look i did coming
into the playoffs
going into the playoffs with the lakers
at full strength
i picked the lakers to win the whole
thing okay i did i thought but the ad
injury is
significant like going without him
against this team
is going to be really tough so we'll see
what lebron can pull out like
invariably he does it right invariably
he does something superhuman that makes
people like me look stupid
but this is a tough tough matchup for
that laker team without a.d
what kind of fallout do you think that
the lakers will have
if they don't get out of the first round
given the circumstances probably not
much
um but do they keep dennis schroeder do
they they get rid of kyle kuzma
uh marc gasol's probably a one and done
do they keep on drinking
your contract because yeah your contract
is around and i don't want him another
year
i i think they're well you kind of stuck
with them though i don't know what you
you know
just wave them and eat the salad i
honestly
this you know and this goes back to a
conversation about
several teams that are facing questions
whether it's boston or miami or whatever
this season has been so weird with covet
issues four games in five
nights myriad injuries the lakers have
been at the forefront of it
i don't think you overreact to the end
result of this season if they get beat
in the first round by phoenix
there are reasons for it right you lost
anthony davis you had a bunch of
injuries that affected your chemistry
andre drummond came in late
you can explain a lot of that away i
think it would be a mistake to just to
you know blow up the lakers you may have
a tough decision to make on dennis
schruter i mean he clearly wants to get
like
you know 20 25 million dollars per year
on a new contract so maybe that's a
tough call but
this is still a laker team dan that when
fully healthy i would favor them going
into next year
i would consider them a favorite going
into next year
who do you like with the clippers and
mavs now
yeah i i dogged the clippers pretty bad
after you know game two because i didn't
think they had the mental toughness to
do what they did over the last couple of
games and
you know we banged on you know playoff p
paul george and
kawhi leonard you know for kind of not
showing up against luca doncic they
showed up
in these last couple of games and again
circumstances
affect kind of what you project the
series to be luke is injured he looked
hurt
in that last couple of games now there's
been reports that he's
feeling better going into this next uh
this game five but
if he's anything but 100 i think the
clippers
have done enough to get back in this
series it's remarkable it really is i
thought this team was done i thought
they would lose
at most in five games maybe even get
swept but the mental toughness
this clipper team showed ty lue the
adjustments he made in defending luka
doncic
it really is an impressive turnaround by
the clippers
great to talk to you again chris thank
you we appreciate your time as always
it's going to be like lakers at six so i
know yeah i know
okay i know keep your head up right yeah
all right that's uh chris mannix the
senior nba writer for sports illustrated